this is the first time that the econ
committee chair attends the Euro group
we all stand to benefit from a good
dialogue with the European Parliament on
the Euro groups work and policy
priorities we also discussed Portugal my
own country the mission witnessed the
good performance of the Portuguese
economy the resilience of the economy to
shocks must continue to be strengthened
and the public that continued to be
reduced on the euro area reform we
already started today with a discussion
on the common backstop to bank
resolution the current entry date is the
1st of January of 2024 and there a
certain set of conditions we could bring
this forward clearly decisions must be
swift timely and allowing national
parliaments to be involved as necessary
when we see about this matter I
professor Christopher bizarre deaths
description field and the present pot on
the field is an EF Nia still is
application form on the table I do hope
it is su intelligence artificial from
the job done faster g- wasn't considered
a yakuza phenomena it no factor has pal
they elevate populist kisaku at fillmore
the political penny in the yoshida
political manya lira postponed could
pass a million in question in me of
format you are afforded from a TV shot
is a bt smokepr simply in terms of
priority first and foremost i will say
from an ECB standpoint we see a
completion of the banking Union as yet
was priority in the near term so we
welcome the agreement reached by the
council in June on the common backstop
to the single resolution fund we believe
that the conditions for operationalizing
the early introduction of the backstop
are now within reach and as a complement
we also believe that by December we
should have a clear timeline for
beginning political discussions on
eddies the European Deposit Insurance
Scheme we also see it as essential
to continue working on designing or
eurozone fiscal capacity on deepening a
new we were asked by the summit to look
at the backstop to work out the details
review the toolkit of the ESM review
existing instruments the possibility or
the need to add instruments if we
succeed in introducing the backstop
earlier before 2024 I think that would
clearly be a positive signal for markets